today's episode is about some may know
him as clarence king
some may know him as james todd it
depends if you were
his black friends or his white friend
this is a wild
wild wild tale my friends yes of as
chrissy said a kid
who said you know what i got i'm in the
last quarter of my life
yeah i always loved black and native
american women yeah i
fell in love with a black woman i'm
gonna lie to her create a false identity
tell her i'm a black kid and i'm gonna
bang her out make five kids one of which
died
and i'm gonna live a double life as a
white man in manhattan and a black kid
in queens
as if the thing is that here's the
here's the thing because clarence king
he died
he died you know over 100 years ago but
if i would have known him he would have
died anyway because make no mistake if
you're clarence king james todd and you
walked past me
i was going to take a bite out of you
because one thing i can't resist black
and white cookies
this kid was a black and white cookie so
well he was white i mean he's white he's
got blonde hair and blue eyes so he
okay so this is the story clarence
he was uh he's a geologist he would
explore he would go out
he's a [ __ ] nerd at the time he was a
nerd at the time though he was pretty
internationally famous
for some things that he'd done he was
exploring what he had done sierra nevada
mountains
at some point he he exposed there was
supposed to be some
some diamond rush and he exposed it
there was no diamonds there he became an
international celebrity he was well
known
he was friends with like um very
prominent people one of which was uh the
grandson
of the john adams president henry adams
henry adams was a good friend of
and some kid hey who was also another
big deal james haye who i think was the
secretary of state or something
so the kid lived in a very prominent
hotel
yeah in manhattan he just lived there
and he was single and then
he would cross the bridge and like put
on a pullman's outfit across the
brooklyn bridge yeah and he was he
married
uh aydah copeland and they had four kids
and he lived a life a double life as a
black guy
uh with her so funny and she didn't know
so funny and
and uh he would he would explain his
absences from there because he would say
i was on the railroad right so he do you
my thing is he must have
in order to pick the perfect profession
so when he's gone
on these geological surveys or whatever
he tells ada copeland his wife he lies
right
guys are good at lying good at lying he
says i'm
not as good as women though that is good
at women yeah yeah women don't have a
lie
they know how to get away with it he but
he was i mean this is pretty good so he
picked the perfect profession
because when he was gone for his
geological surveys which was his real
work or whatever
because you know what i just realized
we're in different seas we're in
different scenes
wow we we're we never swim we never
switched back from wepa
and i'm using your microphone and i got
covered now it's what it is so he would
he would go on these and tell her he was
on the railroad which is the perfect
cover
so that's why she never suspected he was
like oh i'm on the railroad i'm
traveling here i'm traveling there
traveling there but he wasn't it was all
a fiction a lie
the guy lied to her now if you're her on
the deathbed when you say hey by the way
babe
i'm a white woman and she goes that
explains that your piece is what it is
it's what it is
you got a little baby piece yeah she was
like i was expecting a nice black hog
and instead i got this [ __ ]
wart-filled little white dick
do you think she goes oh my god that
makes sense no but you know what i mean
because your hair and your face
you look like a white guy that would all
make sense yeah now it all makes sense
yeah
i think that truly because the kid was
actually making sticks he was making
real money being a geologist
um heading the geological survey and the
kid was making real money they moved
from
uh vinegar hill brooklyn which was a
predominantly uh black area of brooklyn
where they were living but it was there
was a lot of crime there
and it was it was not a good
neighborhood at that time then they
moved to bed-stuy
which bedford stuyvesant was a very
top-notch
brownstone neighbor they moved him there
and then they moved to flush in queens
so they because he kept making so much
money so i part of me thinks
his wife who who was black knew
that he was lying about something most
likely his race or had another affair
was having an affair but because they
were making so much money and she was
able to get her and her
children out of bad neighborhoods and
into better neighborhoods she just
turned a blind eye to it
or maybe she just didn't ask questions
you know yeah which is like hey you know
what money it's what it is i'm not gonna
ask any questions but yeah
the the house in queens was a nice house
and i had four or five kids
then on the death bed he said i'm white
and i'm leaving all this money to you
go get it it's in the care of this
friend you'll get it and then for the
next
30 years she fought for that money
right and she never got it and she had
some very prominent people
represent her to try to get that money
that he was trying to leave
and they wouldn't give her the money
family yeah they wouldn't give her the
money which because
unfortunately he made a deathbed
confession and they weren't going to
accept
the word of a black woman at that time
um
and it's just it's just sad part of
history because he
he wanted to give it to his wife ada
king but wave
his wife who was black but you know what
and then
and then so so these stories happen
where people just
want to change their race for either you
know love
they want the victim mentality they just
are they're so
insecure with their own life
circumstances that they make something
up
he said so his quote was um can you read
this baby mrs king
mr king uh clarence king said he hopes
as he put it
quote no more irish or germans negroes
and english but only americans
belonging to one defined american race
that's what he hoped in 1901
he sent that in 1901 so that's what he
hoped for so he left it
um so there was a 30-year battle this is
also significant
so after he died he tried to leave this
to his uh quote unquote at the time they
would call it negro family
right and um his boy john hay
now that's a boy that's a friend that's
a friend yeah that's how you know a true
friend when like the guy
the guy's not even here to see the good
deed that his friend is doing
i feel like this is something you would
do for me because you're a good friend
here's a
you want to hear a nice little quote
that i think you'll like the um uh
the the sign of a good society is when
old men plant trees
they know the shade they'll never sit
under yeah why'd your jaw pop out of
that beavis
just because i just wanted to [ __ ]
hit you with a quote
but you hit it and then you drop it i
hit the jaw i don't know because make no
mistake i ordered three chains and one
of them just arrived at my house
because we're getting ready for chain
out guys but but that's but but so
that's a good quote but it's a good
quote and it's what john haye
is doing yeah so john hey was actually a
statesman uh
he was a private secretary and assistant
to abraham lincoln i mean this kid
had had abraham lincoln's ear so what
john haye did
and then his his daughter or son
continued to do you don't want to assume
gender yeah
after yeah whatever it was after um
he died he continued to provide ada
copeland
with money a stipend to help every month
that's like my aunts whose husband got
killed
he would get she would get money every
month too from the guys that killed her
husband yeah
that's just mafia rules yeah those guys
i saw saw
your aunt's husband they they saw him he
came and saw him in a different way he
came and saw him in a different way they
took him physically and they took him
physically and now they're on multiple
bars and restaurants on third avenue and
big right and we should be talking about
this on a party it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter with joking
because she did get a paper bag full of
cash
because what are they [ __ ] out of my
eye yeah what are they yeah what are
they [ __ ] mulans
weijong zhang wei zhang
so he continued to provide and so then
there was a 30-year
30-year battle to try to get this money
for her
and and um the um the uh the court
eventually determined in 1933
so 30 years after his death the um
the court decided that uh it was his
daughter helen
it was it was um john haye's daughter it
was his daughter that continued to give
ada copeland a stipend on behalf of his
friend
um after he died so aydah copeland
continued to get this money
and it eventually stopped um and
copeland
uh until her death continued to live in
that house that
john hay his friend had bought for her
she died in 1964 at 101
[ __ ] years
life that is a [ __ ] long long life
and
and during this fight this 30-year
battle to gain control of the trust fund
that he promised her
her representatives included everett
warring who was the first black lawyer
to argue a case before the supreme court
significant and j douglas wetmore who
contested segregation laws in
jacksonville florida
so this was kind of a civil rights fight
and it's kind of an
underrated story in history of a man
who had a love for a black woman who had
a secret family
like your granddad we really hope you
enjoyed that episode whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild
hmm